à six mois des élections
henkouche il prépare déjà la bataille
stratégique du québec pour galvaniser
les troupes
une charge à fond contre son adversaire
libéral justin trudeau a perdu le nord
il dirige un gouvernement d orienter
divisé et en pleine déroute
mais au delà des attaques pas de
nouveaux engagements pour séduire
l'électorat québécois
toujours pas de plan environnemental un
enjeu pourtant très sensible pour le
chef conservateur au québec
ils s'engagent dévoilé une stratégie si
la fin des travaux parlementaires en
juin
notre plan enfin être une vraie qui va
adresser aux frais défi environnemental
de 21 ans touché au premier des cibles
de réduction des gaz à effet de serre
sans les chiffrer pour l'instant je peux
vous dire que nos ces bleus va traire à
rester à est aussi ambitieux mais du
même souffle le chef et les militants
conservateurs se pose en défenseur des
oléoducs et de l'industrie pétrolière
dans un débat dit l'ancien chef du bloc
québécois où les écologistes ont
carrément pris le contrôle mais tous
ceux qui vous disent allez pétrole je
veux pas entendre parler doivent
comprendre que c'est des milliers
d'emplois au québec c'est la richesse
canadienne la question suscite un
malaise chez certaines recrues énergies
nouvelles ma position présentement
partie adversaire libéral déplore
vraiment une division et l'on nous dit
on va revenir pour vous présenter un
père dont on peut pas garder une
population avec l'illusion que quelque
chose va arriver
en attendant le programme néo
conservateurs misent sur des candidats
des figures connues comme ce
commentateur de boxe qui songe à se
lancer
il assène déjà décroché un justin
trudeau on ne porte pas nyx pa manech
carrenet chaque péta train de vider
notre camp c'est pour ça que j'aime
l'intérêt c'est ma première
préoccupation
au delà de l'organisation de terrain le
défi qui attend un d'offrir dans la
province est grand il doit surmonter les
doutes des québécois face au pétrole
albertain aux oléoducs tout en
présentant un plan environnemental
crédible
ici louis blouin radio-canada
victoriaville